i made one video that said this new  twitter thing might be a problem for  facebook and espn hired me to consult  for 5 000 an hour which is why i started  vaynermedia and dave morin from facebook  invited me to go speak at facebook and  that's how i met mark zuckerberg and  that's how i became an angel investor  first know what the [ __ ] you're talking  about does it make sense have you heard  all the other 80 point of views did you  do 20 hours homer cool now you got  something a little bit of your own  unique spin on it now let's make tick  tocks and linkedin because both are  valuable to us because they can get  organic reach because nobody knows who i  am you say one smart thing and one  linkedin and the head of disney theme  park sees it and you get a weird email  and they say can you come in and talk to  me about this start making tick tock and  linkedin videos on how you see it and  then it will come to you what's  practical is content on thoughts that  lead to opportunities